the obr is forecasting the economy won't
grow this year so on a scale of one to
ten how confident are you that we'll see
a growing economy against your objective
this year I said the economy is forecast
to return to growth by the end of the
year which is what I talked about when I
made the speech at the beginning of the
year and I think the measures and
chances budget will help Drive long-term
growth particularly the policy to move
towards full expensing over time and
immediately temporarily for the next
three years if you look at the
productivity gap between the UK and some
of our major competitors like France and
Germany it's a lack of business
investment that explains about half of
that productivity Gap we've perennially
been an economy that under invests in
capital relative to almost all our major
peers and but with the Chancellor's full
expensing policy you know we will now be
the most attractive place for companies
to make those Investments and and I
think that is something that will
ultimately drive up our long-term growth
I was very pleased that in the survey of
about
three or four thousand CEOs from over
100 countries that PWC did recently they
ranked the UK as the number one European
destination for investment and the third
globally behind only the US and China so
that again gives me some confidence that
the policies we've got in place you know
are attracting attention from the right
people and we'll see the benefits of
that over time